[Music]
we're going to discuss discover a tack
any version whether it is going to be in
a form of a check which is the most
common one a piece moves the king gets
in check and something else can get
captured or a piece moves and then
suddenly some two pieces are under
attack for example okay
just very simple position or reasonably
simple position white is to play I will
see I want to see few hand and then we
can discuss this
one
see how about you
Bishop E5 check Bishop E5 check check
and then once the either the king moves
blocks or the bishop being captured what
will you
play excellent now I have a question a
tricky one for everyone let's
assume black queen is
here what shall we play now is yes you
should put the queen
at D4 Queen D4 okay black will just move
his King it's a
move didn't gain anything didn't lose
anything and okay move
yes with will we play the same
move Bishop
E5 but I said that I'm tricky a
bit if we will go Bishop
E5 no it's a
check but the
night right wh why why did we say you
said and I quote because after the
Knight capture what will black play
after Queen takes Queen
right the Knight is going to be
protecting the queen in that version so
it's very nice that you did see
that for example what what would it be
like let's say that I will just tiny bit
change the position white actually has
one move to get some one move to be okay
in this position actually if I will put
the pawn here then white is going to be
way better
but one move for white to get
some Advantage here
yesen G Queen to G4 check black is going
to move his King and then what that's an
excellent move but by the way why why do
you need to play Queen G4 well why did
you play this okay it's a check cool but
what else what is what is black
threatening here black is a big threat
in this position what is
it B the Knight bishop or the queen
right and the bishop it's not easy for
the bishop to move because it no but
it's not easy to move because it's
spinned right it's pinned to the queen
right here over there so Queen G4 is a
very good move not not because it's
check but because it's a forcing move
that breaks the PIN and after the king
moves for example what would be a good
move here for
white I will let you finish everything
can you tell me a good move for
white
yes I think you're
right oh there's a
knight oh yeah why don't we just take
right that's what you wanted to say yeah
just
take now why why is this check not
working but then we can take the queen
no will take the Queen the Knight will
take the queen so we have to
see few moves ahead take and The Queen
Is
Now protected very good so we have to be
careful when we are thinking
about discovered now I mentioned
yesterday the most important discover
check in
chess white is to
play
yes Bishop 87 was this our move as well
Bishop
87 discover check and who is protecting
the queen on d8 no one no one I agree
with
that and let's assume that this was
deposition for a
second I'm not going to give black
another queen that would be too many
queens let's just say this was the
position and why to
play
Bish should be five okay those
discovered checks they are so so
important we we I wanted to say
yesterday but let's say last week it
seems like yesterday we looked at
position like
this and then there was a
question let's say this was the
position and white is too play White
took you see nobody really blunders the
queen so quickly but it's much in much
more smaller doses for example the
question is can black take on D4 or
cannot
cannot why cannot
because this is our idea as well exactly
it's just one more step right we're
going to get to the same exactly same
position we know the pattern just one or
two more steps to get there capture
capture
capture check and get our
check let's say this is the position and
it is white to
play
yes excellent job the bishop is
threatening the king and what are you
going to
win excellent now let's see if we have
this idea in our head let's see if we
can do something tiny bit more difficult
well we have the same POS pretty much
the
same oh yes
please you see I was just looking and
the answer showed up that's the best way
all right it is why to play here very
similar idea but no we need to work tiny
bit
more
yes look to
where last time I did it you know I did
it like jumping bang on the microphone
Ben was laughing at me for entire two
days about how the he came up after the
end of the show and the microphone was
on the floor so I'm not going to do it
again but my heart did it Rook G4
and what is going to get to say what is
this
Pawn today is is he jumping or he cannot
take yes what shall we play K and after
King
h8 this is someone that is thinking
ahead we know that we want to very nice
you solved the idea before so the idea
is in your head so now what you're
thinking is how to get to a similar
pattern right because chess is so much
about patterns if we know like math you
know that oh you can solve this equation
but something is a bit more complicated
well you just want to get from one point
to the other you want to get to a point
that you already know how to solve it
you don't need to go the entire way just
the wait till you get there so if the
king is on this diagonal we're going to
have it
discovered so how do we get the king to
the diagonal we check him the King
enters this this
diagonal and we win excellent
job excellent job okay white is to
play
for
yes D2 Knight to D2
check and winning the queen right yeah
and also Knight C5 is the same right I I
know that's what we want to now I have a
question in this
position to where should we move the
Knight
yes only D2 right why only
D2 perfect perfect to C5 perfect so now
here is my real question to all of you
this was just a war up a warm
up how should white play
in this
position how should white play in this
position
yes y yes such a big surprise well why
not C Rook C8 black has one move King 87
then what king 87 you will play check
black is going to move up with his
King H yeah but but it's the only
move and then you can and then I can do
what no this is this exactly I want I
know that you know I know that you
know actually you know it's quite funny
my idea was to play Knight D2 We were in
this position right we know the pattern
the king stepping on the diagonal the
Knight goes back checking the king the
allows look at how beautiful the Knight
goes back the bishop is checking the
king the Knight attack the queen and
defend this is one hardworking horsey
there but that's correct but
actually it's funny because this is
completely winning the game but for
example when I thought about putting the
position at the beginning I thought
about putting the P here but then there
is a better continuation if someone can
tell me what's the is better
continuation you you'll make an old
chest dude happy that would be
me so I want to see what yes do you see
a better continuation really better oh
right then tell me what's the H King H7
then ah that made me happy I wasn't
joking very good and it also shows us
something tiny bit when we see a good
move in chest should we run Russian
plate
or should we no should we say what to
ourself maybe there is a better move in
this position it doesn't make any
difference Knight F6
is Checkmate Knight D2 would win the
queen and then white would be with a
rook and a knight up 100% winning but in
some position it will be a difference
playing a good move or playing the best
move very good knight F6 is very cool I
like those it's a double check and a
Checkmate and Knight G5 also right
excellent job excellent job all
righty well one more puzzle so let let's
let's look at this position
what should we play
here
yeah watch will white play
here yes um you should move the night um
so the bishop can get
the theing but to where to move the
Knight
where D3 ooh D3 is this correct the r in
the back back I agree perfect Knight
D3 so
check and take the queen I have a
question that's so important
do you get anything just from a
check so
check is nothing but a forcing tool you
don't get any bonuses for a check for
example look at this
position let's say we play this
beautiful check did I get anything
no okay we're going to think carefully
slowly and tell
me what should white be playing here why
to
play
oh many hands okay
uh yeah you came you shall answer yeah
yeah no no the
you check did you get anything from this
check not yet right
maybe you will so what happens after
Bishop F3 check excuse me uh black will
have to do what move with King and then
what you will play
um black is going to move here black is
going to move his King here because it's
the only square that I see possible then
what shall we
play
you see you play The Right Move Bishop
F3 is the right move but not with the
right plan and I was just teaching in
the class before and I said something
moves are meaningless moves have one
purpose one purpose moves fulfill a plan
right you say this is my plan this is my
way how to carry out this plan that's
what moves out if you just I play this
okay what's the plan no plan so you want
you want maybe to see if you can fix it
I'll give you a chance I'll be so Bishop
F3 the king moves to B8 what then um
knight3 you're
safe okay excellent job this is why I
put first the position we remember this
pattern the king is going to be on that
diagonal and then Knight D3 is going to
be well just a very decent move so
Bishop
F3 King steps to
B8 and Knight to D3 but the check itself
on F3 was it was there any point for the
check on F3 if not for this discover
check no all
right all righty we will get something
like this now all my thinking are
sleeping sleeping okay wake up okay
white is to play here what shall we
play
yes to move your Pawn to E5 E5 and then
and and what are we getting from this
beautiful
check yeah you check beautiful what do
we get I'll move the king
somewhere nothing nothing so if we said
I know I should come every class and say
100 times checks without the purpose are
meaningless you know I was asking before
you told me right no new rules in chests
you know 10 checks in a row you get a
pawn 20 checks you get two nothing right
so checks by themselves are meaningless
checks is just a tool to force something
but other than that they are meaningless
so we check here is going to get us
something AI in a guest star
appearance we're going to
which is a check discover Che discover
check which is apparently our topic
today because of you last time and now
what is our idea after this check take
the queen take the queen this I
understand so I have a check and I'm
going to get something from that said
that okay now what about this
position Ben get me a pict
pillow it's really sleepy oh man oh man
you shouldn't have said that okay let's
do it I don't know even which pieces to
throw here just not too many pieces okay
let's let's make it like this
interesting up that will be this okay so
white is to play here so
now why is to
play
yes after you there is a wall and
actually I do speak to the wall but not
now okay PA takes C Pawn takes C4 but
are you getting anything with Pawn takes
C4 I will move the queen let's let's say
Pawn takes C4 black has one move to play
I'll play this
move did you get anything you got you
wanton a pawn maybe but you have
something so so so so so much
better
okay do we want to tell me okay so tell
me r a check Rook A8 check which moves
should black play consider to
play King at some point King H7 will be
played whether it is Bishop d8 and then
we're going to take it and then King
goes to H7 okay what will happen once he
goes to 87 what then then then
what and then
what that's perfect you
see not so complicated to make an old
chess coach happy just find two moves in
a row that are perfect very very good so
discovered checks are quite serious
okay now we will touch a topic and then
actually not next week because next week
it will be Thanksgiving weekend but two
weeks from today ADI you or someone else
that remembers have to be here to remind
me that we are going to look at double
checks if not I will forget here we put
in our head double checks double check
double checks remind Ronan double checks
double check double check double checks
okay so what are
double check double check is ex and why
did I do that I have also no idea okay
just to give b a tiny heart attack all
righty what are double
check yes two and basically for a double
check does it is it some it has to be a
discovered right because basically there
is no other way for a double check to
occur unless a piece moved and then the
piece that moved is threatening a check
and a piece that it was
blocking threatening a check
right there is no no no other way for a
check ever to occur I will say is this
position possible is this position
possible what was the last move that was
played in this
position oh
easy it's easy so what was the last
move the Knight
E6 that's perfect if I tell
you
that this
position is this position
possible no no yes no if you if it's
possible then just tell me what was the
last move that was played here well The
Rook is in check the king is in check by
The Rook where did the queen go
there I don't see anywhere but
but is this position possible yes what
was the last
move to remind me two weeks right it's a
long time so you have to answer it
correctly the
pressure perfect perfect so double check
has to be by definition discovered
attacking the Queen the king and it is
the most forcing move in chess the most
most most most because if in check we
can
move block or capture here we only have
to move here let's look at this funny
position and let's see how it all
connects white has two double check and
two
discover the attack which move is better
here which move moves are better here
okay I want us to speak about all four
them see the waving his hand has to
answer so you tell me which move you
will play
here Bishop B7 but you have a double
check no double check because double
check means I know S I know your answer
is right but Bishop C6 is beautiful it's
a double check I know black has to move
the king but after black moved the king
what did white
get nothing is perfect yeah how about
how about Bishop C G6 I know it's a
double check but what did white
get but what about Bishop B7 the queen
and there is another way to get the
queen another
way yes um I think
d d D3 exactly attacking
the king and the Queen and that is going
to be our topic which is just
continuation of
discovered attacking to double check
which sometimes sometimes you can
combine them all that's then it's a
really really extremely powerful for
example
this position best move for us
now
[Music]
yes that's our move and actually to be
to be also honest also this move is
strong enough but Bishop C6 looks it's a
double
check and winning the queen so it's the
most forcing possibly but it always
always always depends a check is not
necessarily good because hey it's a
check a double check is not necessarily
good because hey it's double check no
forcing the opponent is one thing we can
see and anti and know what his reply
going to be much more likely if it's
good for us we can force
[Music]
it
ah